our next guest is a celebrated NFL
player but is for known for being
married to the incredibly talented and
beautiful Sierra she is wildly
successful as a singer and a performer
and has appeared in several movies
including thats my boy alongside man she
is also incredibly dedicated to her
community and charity work can't say
enough about her why she married a minor
league baseball player we'll never know
please welcome Russell Wilson
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
see once again you guys get complimented
all the time and then you come in you're
angry and you start throwing the
football at us you guys know what's best
for you McLovin yeah it's um good hands
brother thanks man
FCC High School receiver or something
what he be on the All Hands team on the
Seahawk no he would not be no okay
kind of like a tight end like a backup
well he'd be like a Wilson type he'd
definitely be like a walkthrough uh kind
of uh All Hands team guy like a practice
square the guy
oh no not practice squad the guy that
you kind of just throw in there to
really get hit were you ever on the
kickoff team no I never did kick off I
did everything on high school except for
kickoff return and and kickoff were you
any good as a returner I was I was
pretty good punt returner
so but but it like compared to who you
have now I was way better no Tyler is
amazing if she was sick if Tyler Lockett
couldn't play I'd fair catch it every
time I would love to see that
I don't think Pete Carroll would love to
see that but I win one all right did you
guys have a successful season yeah I
thought I thought yeah you know the end
of the day you won the whole thing
I think every time we step on the field
it's that's the intent but how do you
measure success after having won a Super
Bowl been to another one and then what
happens well I think you measure success
by the growth that you have for other
season I think a lot of people thought
we were gonna be terrible
you know everybody thought we were gonna
suck and be you know you know 2 and 2
and 14 or something like that and that's
not gonna happen
yeah did you have doubts at all cuz you
know we sort of got rid of the legion of
boom
you had injuries there Oh slow start did
you have any doubts no I didn't have any
positivity I didn't have any doubts cuz
I saw I saw the transition moment when
we got back to OTAs in just everybody
being in tune everybody working together
so that was the exciting part so I
didn't have any doubts in that you know
and you never know until you get to the
field I think the one thing that
you know I I firmly believe in is is
that you know every time you step on the
field you get you know we give ourselves
a great chance to win and that's what we
always want to do is it's about winning
give me the quarterback that you watch
there's two guys I watched the most now
I'm talking during a game you're on the
sideline that you might go let me take
it let me sneak a peek at what yeah I'm
at watch them all I think that the guys
I watched you know throughout film and
even sideline sometimes definitely drew
drew Brees I watched Tom you know but
what do you see when you see those I
want to have the process in the game you
know trying to be in their position what
they would be doing how I would do it
you know and and just you know really
trying to figure out how they're
processing it you know you know Tom's
you know 41 or whatever he is you know
Drew's almost um just turned 40 I think
so you think about how good those guys
have been over time you know over you
know over the past you know 15 years
plus but he know all the answers too so
he goes to line of scrimmage sees what
you got yeah does he already know the
answers to the defense I think they'll
lead quarterbacks do for sure I think I
think what we we go up to the line you
never know all the answers but I think
you know most of them think you know how
to get out of situations I think you'd
also know that every play is not gonna
be the best play but how do you make it
a good play when's the last time you
went to line of scrimmage in you go
touchdown before you even let a lot of
time but most give me one that where you
go this is gonna be a touchdown man I
would say Kansas City game you know I
think you know the you know I'm trying
to think what else I mean there's a lot
of times you throw a lot of touchdowns
throughout the season you feel like okay
this is gonna be the play that happens
that happens a lot that means a lot but
but you got to kind of hide your your
excitement there yeah be a little actor
you know a little bit you you want to
have the same mannerisms you want to you
know sometimes you know what the matchup
is you may have Doug Baldwin on a
certain guy you may have to lock it on a
certain guy with you know if it's Chris
Carson coming on the backfield you kind
of know hey this can be a good play
when eminem mentioned you in in his song
monster
woody what did you make about what we
had actually just played up funny things
we just played a Monday night game I'll
never forget this was like three four
years ago we had just played a money in
that game and my quarterback coach at
the time Coach Karl Smith tater I call
him he's saying have you heard the song
I said what song and it just came out
like that like that day or something
yeah and and it was mmm so that was
pretty you met Eminem III have ran
across so I haven't really had the
chance to really meet him one on one
so no what would you I mean you don't
strike me as that sure kind of music no
I was I listen to I listen to music like
that I listen to rap and stuff like that
but you know I mostly I'm more of an R&B
old-school kind of soul guy but you know
but music is a big part of my life
that's for sure yes McLovin what we have
negative draft profiles Russell I did
not write these I want him to know that
to be sure okay you want I wanna I want
to see your draft profile okay so this
is Russell Wilson jr. the third and now
everybody's done this breeze did it yep
breeze got angry and kept it all keeping
then he he put it in his locker he said
I won't look at it every single this is
two years ago don't worry I'll have this
okay all right here you go
so all right so Russell Wilson his
height will be his biggest inhibitor at
the next level remains to be seen if he
can throw effectively in the pocket of
the next level not able to step up and
into the pocket like other quarterbacks
mmm make dubious late-game decisions
sometimes ops are scrambled too quickly
before making all of his progressions
although he has a quality arm that's
quality quality arm would never be a
prototypical NFL quarterback could fit
in as a part-time specialist coming off
the bench Wow
now Paula his names are those who wrote
that if you care
drew brees low and Christian McCaffrey
said I would love to have names who said
this about names address I know you've
talked about team bows before and you
talked about Tali I want to give you
opportunity to do I know you're short on
time well yes I think the cool thing
about bows you know music is a big part
as you know my life as you mentioned my
wife earlier Sierra as you love her
I do interesting I do you know from afar
so yeah boasts a big part of it you know
we listen to music all the time
constantly keeps me focused in
everything else the QC 35 you know to
headphones have been now they have these
new Bose frames you mentioned to
Christian McCaffrey about dancing right
yeah so I got something queued up for
your brother okay you put those on okay
I want to put a song on I want you to
dance to it okay because he loves Ciara
so much okay now tell me at this place
let me know if I met you may have to hit
the button alright let me see here okay
let me let me hit the little button
right here it's right here a little gold
button underneath the bottom right under
the frame right frankly bad okay now you
hear something ya know says now you go
playing level up for them you got a
dance to that though you know I would
but I just got my knee replaced just
just do this just do this for me Dan
just do this well this is nice yeah so I
rock those you can do phone calls
everything on these things I've been I
was wearing these things the whole time
would have been nice if you brought an
extra pair but now it's nice you know
what Dan I got an extra pair in the car
that's for you but nothing
uh you have to go yeah I think I got to
go you go there's more stuff but all
right always fun be on your ship oh
thank you for coming by and please tell
your wife I shut it off okay so are you
guys a download tally Dan load tally
it's a fun new predictions app you can
play the super bowl game it's really
really cool predictions kind of like the
HQ but of live events Super Bowl you
went up to $250,000 playing the game of
tallies plate Alan calm yeah go to play
telecom is pretty sick
Russell Wilson jr. the third thank you
for more Dan Patrick show tune to
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]